[Música]
actualizamos las noticias de la economía
en France 24 aquí en directo América
saludo en el estudio entonces a mi
compañero Juan Pablo lucubí qué tal Juan
Pablo acá estamos otra vez con
actualizando las noticias así es y vamos
a empezar con una noticia que tiene que
ver con Twitter porque su dueño y los
hizo un anuncio importante de qué se
trata pues anunció que en el plazo de
seis semanas alguien más lo reemplaza lo
reemplazará como sí o de la compañía y
ya se empieza a hablar de linda yacarino
la jefa de publicidad global de nbc
Universal quien ya renunció a su cargo
Julia bristein de cnbc aseguró a los
medios estadounidenses que ella estaba
en conversaciones porque ella quería
trabajar precisamente con El Magnate
pero pues él no ha confirmado nada hasta
el momento y ya se empiezan a avanzar en
este tipo de temas el multimillonario
propietario también de la empresa de
cohetes spacex ya había anunciado en
noviembre quedaría Este paso con el que
pasará a ser solamente director
ejecutivo de tecnología las acciones de
tesla pues la compañía de autos de lujo
de elon musk tuvieron un movimiento
positivo de 3,54% después del cierre de
la bolsa esto el día de ayer y la
noticia Se recibió positiva Porque
algunos ejecutivos de tesla incluso han
criticado que mosc pues que él no está
lo suficientemente concentrado en su
compañía de carros eléctricos por estar
ocupándose de los escándalos que ha
traído consigo la red social el límite
de la información que se publica en
Twitter y hasta la certificación de las
cuentas así hizo el anuncio El Magnate
emocionado denunciar que he contratado a
un nuevo ceo para Twitter comenzará en
seis semanas mi rol pasará a ser
presidente ejecutivo y seteó
supervisando productos software y cyzops
bueno veremos entonces y con el
nombramiento de jaccarino merman también
un poco estas polémicas que se dan casi
que a diario con la empresa
Juan Pablo vamos a hablar ahora de las
reuniones del g7 que se desarrollan en
Japón es el segundo día de la Cumbre de
finanzas del g7 en la ciudad de niágata
ahí están Pues los representantes de
Estados Unidos Japón Alemania Reino
Unido Francia Italia y Canadá además de
la Unión Europea quienes están
discutiendo hoy sobre la necesidad de
hacer que las cadenas de suministro
mundiales sean más resilientes para
reducir la dependencia excesiva de china
en un borrador de la declaración
conocido por un medio local japonés los
líderes financieros aseguran estar
listos para tomar medidas para mantener
la estabilidad financiera global pero
hablando puntualmente de las cadenas de
suministro no todos se mostraron de
acuerdo lo pueden hacer esfuerzos en
contra de China para darle un ejemplo de
Estados Unidos con la secretaria del
tesoro Janet yelen pidió más controles
específicos para contrarrestar lo que
llamó coerción económica de China contra
otros países pero Japón que dependen
parte de los movimientos económicos de
China se mostró escéptico debido al
enorme impacto que podría tener esta
acción contra china que es la segunda
economía más grande del mundo pese a no
estar en el privilegiado grupo de los
siete Juan Pablo momento de conocer Los
indicadores Y empezamos con Estados
Unidos porque los tres principales
indicadores abrieron en positivo y
también en otras noticias de ese país
porque la reunión entre el presidente
Joe biden y el presidente de la cámara
de representantes que vive mccarthy que
estaba agendada para hoy queda pospuesta
para la próxima semana y da más
incertidumbre a este tema del techo de
la deuda las bolsas de América Latina
cerraron mixtas el jueves con el Call
cap de Colombia liderando las pérdidas
entre sus pares de la región Mientras
que el merval de Argentina volvió a
encabezar por tercera jornada
consecutiva las en América Latina el
cierre de Asia se dio mixto con Tokio
con ganancias y Hong Kong con pérdidas y
bien cuéntenos Cuál es nuestra cifra del
día Andrés son los 70 dólares que cuesta
el juego más ambicioso de Nintendo
hablamos de the legend of Zelda Tears of
Kingdom que salió al mercado este
viernes los usuarios esperaron seis años
para esta última saga de juegos de Zelda
y ya se podrá imaginar usted la cantidad
de fila que le están haciendo a este
juego para comprarlo de primero Así es
Juan Pablo entonces de esta manera
terminamos la información económica nos
vemos entonces la próxima semana con más
información sobre la economía la próxima
semana nuestra compañera Daniela Blandón
aquí en estudio así es